and what I've said a lot of times is we
need to bring bullying back the reason
why I say that is because bullying is a
very natural way of letting you know
that you're inadequate with your peers
right and if they tell you hey you're
fat or hey you're a loser Etc a lot of
the self-improvements that I've made
right throughout my adolescence into my
adulthood came from people bullying me
and people say oh but his trauma is bad
no you need that you need to be smacked
in the face sometimes and learn you're
not good enough right now you need to
become better and the thing is now we
have a participation trophy Society
where just by showing up you're rewarded
and quite frankly that's not enough it's
not about just showing up it's about
being consistent and showing up every
day and doing it correctly